ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Hello everybody.
Welcome.
My name is Eric Koleda.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer working on Google
Apps Script.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: My name
is Matt Ziegelbaum.
I'm a Software Engineer and
I work on Google Forms.
ERIC KOLEDA: And today, we're
going to show you how you can
take the simple, scalable data
collection of Google Forms and
combine it with the powerful,
integrated automation of Apps
Script to eliminate a lot of
the manual processes, the
annoying workflows you have to
do in your daily routine.
But first, let's take a look
back at where we've come from.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So I guess
maybe sometimes we all feel a
bit like this, sitting in
a room processing paper.
This is the Sears Roebuck
Fulfillment Center Entry
Department from about
100 years ago.
This postcard is from 1916, and
it kind of illustrates how
far we've come.
Back at the turn of the century,
Sears figured out
that you could turn
form processing
into an assembly line.
They filled rooms throughout
the country with people who
had to move forms from point A
to point B at various time
points, and it cut their error
margins, it increased their
profitability, it made their
customers happy, but it's
really manual.
And moving forward, today,
this is fairly standard.
Enterprise software, you build
these big enterprise systems.
They do your order
fulfillment.
Your user comes to your website,
you click a button,
all of a sudden the warehouse
gets the order, it ships out.
But it's still big, it requires
a lot of costly
engineering work, and
you can do better.
ERIC KOLEDA: And the truth is
there's a lot of problems that
aren't solved by using
a really big system.
For lack of a better term, I'm
going to refer to these as
mini-workflows.
So these are processes that you
have that are often maybe
very small in scope.
So sometimes we try to
plan a team dinner.
I'm not going to build an
enterprise application for a
team dinner.
Other times, they're just
limited time frame.
So let's say you're doing
an event registration.
When that event is over in a
couple weeks, no longer is
that entire workflow system
necessary, so it doesn't make
sense to invest too
much in it.
And sometimes, there's just
processes that are really
rapidly changing.
So think crisis response.
You're on the ground and you
need to quickly adapt your
workflow to what's happening,
and having something big,
clunky, and hard baked is just
not going to scale to what you
need it to do.
Now, we use different kinds of
technology today to address
these problems.
I think one of the
first things that
people turn to is email.
What's great about email is that
it really requires the
minimal effort out of
all the things we're
going to talk about.
You just start typing and hit
the Send button, and your
workflow is off and running.
And the other great thing about
it is the technology is
really familiar.
Even your least technical user
in your organization has an
inbox and knows how
to work it.
Otherwise, they probably
wouldn't be
employed there any longer.
But once you scale a workflow
like this to something beyond
just a handful of users,
it really turns
into complete chaos.
Trying to collect all
that data, organize
it, even handle edits.
People change their
response later.
Trying to process all of that
in email really breaks down,
and I think people quickly
realize this is not the way to
go for something that has any
degree of complexity.
Now, where a lot of people turn
to next, and an obvious
choice, is spreadsheets.
Spreadsheets are a great tool
for doing data organization
and collection, mostly because
it's structured.
So unlike email, you can define
columns and rows, you
can organize your data into
different fields, really add
some much needed structure
to what you're doing.
And although it's a little bit
more complicated than email,
it's still relatively
simple to set up.
I find that people, when
they're working on a
spreadsheet, they'll probably
spend more time getting the
background colors just the way
they want than they actually
do on the rows and columns
and the important bits.
But once again, there's still
a problem here in that it's
somewhat error prone.
So we use Google Sheets,
obviously, inside Google for
all of our work, and I've been
in sheets open before that
have hundreds of little cursors
flying around adding
rows, changing cells,
overwriting what I just entered.
It's still kind of dangerous
because all the data is
available for everybody to both
view and edit, and so it
really doesn't scale to a more
complex kind of mini-workflow.
Now, I imagine a bunch of us
here in the room are software
developers, and so our natural
inclination, when we see a
problem like this is, I can
just I an application.
I know how to do it.
I could spin up a database
and a server.
Lickety split, not a problem.
Actually I have a colleague,
[? Khalyan, ?]
no matter what problem I tell
him in my life, he always says
that with just a weekend of
coding and maybe [INAUDIBLE],
he could solve it.
Doesn't matter how complex
the problem is.
And the truth is there are
some benefits to custom
applications.
You can tailor your application
to your exact needs.
Just expose the data you want,
just collect the data you
want, have the exact sequences
and branching.
So it's really perfect for
getting the exact solution
that you would like to have.
And if you build it on the right
technologies, it can
easily scale to thousands
of users.
The scalability problem
for number of
users really goes away.
But there's a cost here and a
problem that isn't always
obvious at first, and that's
the long term maintenance.
So just by a show of hands,
how many people here have
built an application for a
friend or colleague that they
swore was a two week project,
and it's years later and
you're still supporting it?
A lot of hands went up there.
You're getting the calls.
Can you add a label?
Can you add a field?
You've got to remember a
password to a system you
probably long ago forgot.
There's an ongoing cost of these
custom applications that
doesn't make sense in more of
these mini-workflow scenarios.
But at Google, we think we
have a better option for
addressing it.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yes.
So we think that option
is Google Forms.
Google Forms started in 2008
as a feature of Google
Spreadsheets, and we wrote it to
address problems like this
where you had a lot of
information you needed to
collect-- say, going
to dinner--
and you had too many users, and
there just wasn't a great
way to plan well.
Google Forms is perfect for
these short, flexible
solutions that you need
to create on the fly.
Crisis response is perfect.
Teachers love it.
Just recently after the Boston
bombings, the community
actually threw together two
forms and sent them out to the
world, one form for people who
got stuck because of grounded
flights and couldn't leave the
city and didn't have anywhere
to stay, and the other
form for people who
could provide housing.
And ad hoc, they set up an on
the fly solution and got
everyone a place to stay.
They got first responders
food.
And it was all through using
this simple technology.
In February, we launched a new
version of Google Forms.
It's much richer.
It looks like Docs,
Sheets and Slides.
It supports real time
collaboration, and it scales
better than the old version.
So as [? Sundar ?]
noted this morning, Apps for
Education is huge, and
teachers are some of our most
enthusiastic Forms users.
They love it.
They work to create quizzes and
parent feedback forms and
all of these things that
just make their
lives so much easier.
But it's all manual, if a
student joins the class
halfway through the year and
they add it to their roster
spreadsheet, it's not in all of
their forms, and it's hard.
Teachers don't have infinite
time and their resources are
already stretched, and they
really need more automation.
They want to be able to quickly
create quizzes.
They want to send feedback forms
to parents to find out
what they can do better.
There's just a whole slew of
things that they need to do.
And luckily, Google has had a
solution for automating things
with Google Apps for years.
ERIC KOLEDA: And that's
Google Apps Script.
So some of you might already
know what Google Apps Script
is, judging from
the talk title.
But if you haven't heard of it,
there's basically a few
takeaways about what
Apps Script is.
So the first is that it's
JavaScript in the cloud.
What that means is you're
writing JavaScript code, but
you're writing it in an online
editor that gets stored in
Google Storage and then runs
on Google hardware.
And so since all of this is
taking place in the cloud, it
really requires no set
up whatsoever.
So right now, you could
open a web browser to
script.google.com and start
coding immediately.
No IDE, no binaries, no
configuration or setup steps.
It's really a lightweight way to
get coding in a Google Apps
environment.
And another great thing about it
is that it gives you really
easy access to all your data.
So we have connectors
into a lot of
different Google services--
Gmail, Calendar, Docs,
and Drive--
so you can pull out your Google
data and start doing
interesting things with it.
But we also have connectors into
outside technologies and
outside data so you can
interface with third party
APIs, you can interface with
legacy systems that you have,
and it's a really great way
to bring all of your data
together and then take action
and extend Google Apps.
I don't have it in the slide,
but there's a fourth thing I
would recommend you remember
about Apps Script.
Please do not refer
to it as GAS.
My colleague Arun, it really
bugs him that he's the Lead
Developer Advocate on GAS.
But that's a small point.
Now, we've had Google Apps
Script in Google Sheets and
Google Sites for a number
of years now.
It's been really popular.
And just yesterday, we were so
happy to announce that Apps
Script is now in Google
Forms as well.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC KOLEDA: There we go.
All right.
So we really think this opens
up a whole lot of great
potential for solving these
mini-workflow problems and
getting these manual tasks
completely automated.
So what does it mean to have
Google Scripts in Forms?
Well, the first thing you'll
notice right away is in the
Forms Designer, there's a new
menu, Tools, Script Editor.
This is how you jump right
into creating a
script for your form.
You can just start coding right
away, and it provides
you really easy access to the
currently open form so you can
start taking action on it.
And really, it bundles together
the script and the
form so that if you were to
copy that form or share it
with someone, the script
moves along with it.
So it's a really great way
to take a workflow, a
mini-workflow solution, bundle
it up, and move it along.
Now, what can you actually
do now that you have a
script in your form?
Well, there's basically three
main ways that we're
integrated with Forms.
The first is the ability to
create, open, and edit forms
programmatically using
Apps Script.
Second is to enhance the Form
Designer with your own custom
user interface components.
And third is to react to form
submissions and carry that
into another action.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So
let's take a look at
create, open, and edit.
The most important thing that
we wanted to give to you in
this new API is that if you can
do something in the Form
Designer, you should be able
to do it in Apps Script.
So we worked really hard to
make sure all of that
functionality is there.
You can manage your forms.
You can change basically
everything about them from
their confirmation message, to
the choices of a check box
field, to whether or not the
form is currently accepting
responses, and this opens up
a whole slew of things.
You can generate new forms
programmatically.
If you had those quizzes that
you need to send to your
students, you can do that now.
If you want to make dinner plans
using a form and you
have to plan a dinner once a
month for someone's birthday,
all of a sudden, you can click a
button and make that happen.
So just taking a quick look
at some code snippets.
You can see here we
have FormApp.
FormApp is the new service to
interact with Google Forms.
Services are Apps
Script's way of
interacting with Google services.
We already had DocumentApp,
SpreadsheetApp, GmailApp, and
a whole bunch of others, so
FormApp should be familiar.
If you're familiar with this
script editor already, just
type FormApp and a period,
and you'll get the nice
auto-complete you expect
from Apps Script.
Moving on, setting values.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday are
the days I can go to dinner.
We're not going to dinner when
I can't go because I'm
organizing this.
And finally, sending it over
to the team is really easy.
Using the Mail App and just a
couple of lines, we've sent
out a script.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
So that's creating, opening,
and editing, but the next
thing we want to take a look
at is enhancing the Form
Designer itself.
So there's basically
three types of
things you can enhance.
The first is you can add your
own custom menus into the Menu
Bar that blend in seamlessly
with the menus that are
already there.
Secondly, you can show simple
prompts and alerts, little
pop-ups that allow you to
collect information from your
user or show them some little
small piece of information.
And then if you want to build
a more rich form of
interaction, you can actually
design your own UIs, your own
more complex, custom built user
interfaces, and expose
those as a dialog or even
in the sidebar.
The sidebar is especially great
when you're designing a
form because you can keep
your information up
while taking action.
Now, what that allows you
to do, I think first and
foremost, is kind
of make macros.
So you may find yourself in the
Form Designer doing the
same kind of repetitive tasks
over and over again, things
like refreshing the values in
a list, like Matt mentioned
before, or maybe some sort of
sorting, or some sort of
updating task.
Maybe you had a form previously
that you were
changing some text
on every week.
Now you can automate that.
And taking that script and
actually exposing it by a menu
item makes it a lot more
approachable to
nontechnical users.
We found that a lot of users,
the act of opening a script
and hitting the little
Run button, that
just scares them away.
They see code and they're
out the door.
But when you expose it by a
menu item, they don't even
need to know that this is not
a built in feature, and so
it's very approachable.
And then the other thing you can
do with enhancing the UI
is bring forward
relevant data.
So when you're designing a form,
it may be helpful to
have built into that interface,
if you're a
teacher, a list of your classes
or students, or your
organization.
Perhaps you could even just
show your calendar or your
Gmail, some information that
when you're designing a form
would be really nice to have,
not only to see, but then to
take action with in
a complex way.
So now let's go back to this
dinner planning example we've
been showing you thus far, and
let's say we have our form
built, that we had generated in
the previous code example.
But now we want to have some
extra menu items there that
allow me, has the form
maintainer, to quickly get a
sense of what the responses
are like thus far.
So I've injected an extra menu
here called Extras, and the
code to do so is
pretty simple.
It's basically just passing in
some strings, which is the
text that should appear in the
menu, as well as the function
that should be run when that
menu item is clicked, so it's
very simple just to tie together
your code and a menu.
So the two menu items I've added
here is one, to show me
based on all the responses,
what's the best day thus far
based on everyone's
submissions.
And then maybe even just show
me a chart in case I want to
analyze the relative popularity
of given days.
So let's look at this first
one, showBestDay.
So I have some Calculate Best
Day method here using my super
secret algorithm that I have
not shown you, but
essentially, once you've figured
out what your best day
is, to actually expose that
to the user as an alert is
basically just one long
line of code.
You can even set custom buttons
so you can have a
little bit of control over OK,
Cancel, Yes, No, things of
that nature, and then
even react to
which button they choose.
Now, the other menu item was to
show a chart, and this is a
little bit more of
a rich interface.
It's not just a string, so it
requires you to use a custom
dialog or sidebar.
So in this case, I've built up
a user interface using the
HTML service.
Now, this is a little bit more
complicated and so I haven't
shown the code here, but we
have some really great
documentation in our Developer
Docs that show you exactly how
to use the HTML service.
So once you've gotten your HTML
page built up and your
application is wired and ready
to go, to actually show it to
the user in the Form Designer
is dead simple.
It's just this one line,
showDialog, passing in your
finished HTML object.
It's the same thing for
showSidebar as well.
And so in this case, I used some
very, very crude HTML and
CSS to draw a little bar chart,
but you could imagine
the possibilities that, once
you have the full HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS stack in
front of you, the kind of rich
user interfaces you could build
directly into Google Forms.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So finally,
we can now react to
submissions.
If you're familiar with the
Spreadsheets [INAUDIBLE], the
Form Submit has always
been there but
it hasn't been great.
It's not rich.
It's just been a key
value store.
And so now, you can still
detect when a user has
submitted a form and you can
read the data of the response,
but you get a new, rich response
object out of it.
So you can build complicated
workflows that react to
submissions.
You can send responses based
on the other response.
You can build forms based
on forms based on forms.
So back to dinner.
You can see here a trigger,
and if you're not familiar
with them, triggers are Apps
Script's way of hooking up one
of your custom functions
to an event.
So for every response that's
submitted, this onFormSubmit
function will be called.
Looking at the response from a
user, you can see that the
response is easily parsed.
You can get their email out
and you can see which days
they're available.
You can very easily, using the
DocumentApp, put their
response into a document that
everyone who has responded can
see, simplifying your life
because you're no longer the
one person who knows all of the
information, and giving
everyone this simple access
to this information.
ERIC KOLEDA: So we've shown you
the three basic components
here of the interaction that you
can do with Google Forms--
create, open, and edit, enhance
the designer, and
react to submissions.
Now we're going to go through
a little demo showing how we
put them all together to address
a real, live use case.
So something that's become
popular in college--
a little after my time, though--
is these clickers.
I don't know how many people
have seen these before.
But essentially, it's a way
for a teacher to really
quickly poll their students,
kind of give them
an on the fly quiz.
So they can ask a question.
Students have a clicker in their
hand and just push A, B,
or C, and then the teacher gets
a readout with how many
students are correct, how many
people are actually getting
the lecture.
Now, there's a cost involved
here, and a lot of public
schools, they don't have the
money to buy these for all
their classrooms.
And so one of our colleagues,
[INAUDIBLE], he's a PM focused
on education within Google, the
EDU market, and actually a
former teacher himself.
He saw our new integration and
he thought this could be a way
to solve that problem that's
completely free and built on
Google apps.
And so we're going to go
and show that demo now.
The basic idea that he had was,
what if you could create
a form that allowed you to
generate forms, kind of that
meta universe that Matt
was talking about.
So what we've built here is
the Quick Quiz Creator.
So this is a form that the
teacher would fill out to on
the fly generate a new quiz to
distribute to their students.
So Matt's going to fill
out an I/O quiz here.
So you give it a name
and a description.
Those are optional.
And then there's a bunch of
different text boxes that
allow you to specify the
questions and then multiple
choice answers.
And the nice thing about this,
you could obviously create a
custom UI that did all of this,
collecting data from a
teacher, but once again, it
highlights that a teacher will
be really familiar with
Google Forms itself.
And so going in and creating a
quiz via a form is actually a
low training, low effort way of
getting all of that data,
and allows them to, right after
their class is over or
after the lecture is over,
to sit down, throw a quiz
together, and distribute it in
just a matter of seconds.
So at the bottom here, we're
selecting which of our classes
we want to submit this to,
and we have a little
Other box as well.
And then once you hit Submit,
you get a little message
saying that your quiz is being
created, and this is where the
Apps Script picks up.
So now, we're in the part of
our script that's actually
reacting to a form submission.
We detected the submission,
and we're reacting.
And what our action is going
to be is a couple things.
We're building a brand new form
on the fly based on that
form's responses, and then we
are sending out that form to
the teacher.
Now, we're sending it to the
teacher first because the
teacher needs to give us
the correct answers.
And so once again, we're using
the form as a way to get that
information.
So here, Matt, as the teacher,
is going to go in and fill out
the correct answers
for his quiz.
So now this second form-- not
the original form-- this
second form was just submitted,
but we also
captured that event.
So we have the ability to have
a single script react to the
events of multiple
different forms.
It's getting a little complex,
I know, but it's pretty cool.
So now that that is done, we
should get an email here, and
the second window on the
right is the student.
So this is a separate account in
CS 101, which obviously is
very concerned with
my shirt color.
And now the student gets an
email saying, you've got a new
quiz that you need to take.
So they see the same form
again, but now they're
choosing what their answers
are to the quiz.
They're taking the quiz.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: They're
not paying attention.
ERIC KOLEDA: They're apparently
quite wrong.
So that's great.
So now we have the student
filling out the form, the
teacher's got the
correct answers,
everything's generated.
But how do we then see how the
class is doing, what the
responses are like thus far?
So this is where we've then used
the Enhance the Designer
integration that we talked about
before to add our own
custom menu called
Quiz Results.
And it just has one function,
Show Sidebar, which is going
to pop up a sidebar that
shows the results of
your quiz thus far.
So this is a custom UI that
we've built using the HTML
service, and you can see,
there is our I/O quiz.
And in just a moment--
OK, so these zeros obviously
don't render quite as well.
But if we give it some correct
answers, there we go.
Now we're getting some
percentages.
So we're drawing little bars and
updating the values about
what the percentage correct is
on these different quizzes.
So it's pretty cool.
So as a teacher, you
really quickly, in
just a matter of moments--
you just thought of the
quiz just after
finishing your lecture--
filled out the form, filled out
the correct answers, sent
it to your students, and have
live feedback about how
they're doing.
Now, we are actually interested
in seeing this
happen live for the whole room,
so we prepared ahead of
time a quiz.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
So if you have a laptop
out or you have your
phone, get it ready.
We've made this quiz for you.
It's very hard.
You have to figure out if
someone is a Turing Award
winner or if it's
IKEA furniture.
We've made the link a
short link for you.
It's large.
If you can't read it,
it's goo.gl/tPSCH.
ERIC KOLEDA: So as responses
start streaming in, we should
see this start to update.
Now, I know you actually took
this quiz multiple times.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: I've taken
this quiz multiple times, but
I still get things wrong
occasionally.
ERIC KOLEDA: It is harder
than it looks.
Getting those answers in.
Are you guessing again?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: I'm
guessing again.
ERIC KOLEDA: Just a moment.
We're going to use the
mics for questions.
Not quite streaming
in there, huh?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Not quite.
ERIC KOLEDA: Want to show the
sidebar again and see if we
can load it up fresh?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Sure.
ERIC KOLEDA: Close
that dialog, too.
I think we're screwing it up.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: The
perils of live demos.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, if the keynote can't do
it, what chance do we have?
Well, we're going to keep this
up during the question and
answer portion, so hopefully,
we can revisit back to what
your answers are.
But it is actually pretty cool
that we can collect all this
information really quickly,
show it right into the
designer, and kind of have just
one simple interface for
a teacher to do these results.
Here we go.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Still
nothing, though.
ERIC KOLEDA: Wait, wait.
There we go.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM:
And there we go.
ERIC KOLEDA: 127.
Wow, that was fast.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
You guys were fast.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I think the correct answers--
actually, I don't know if people
are still submitting,
so I don't want to ruin it.
We'll get to the correct answers
during the question
and answer at the end.
All right.
Back to slides?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
So the takeaway from our
presentation, once again, is
that Forms allows you to do
simple and scalable data
collection, and then when you
combine that with Apps Script,
our integrated, powerful
automation, you can really do
some amazing things in a very
low tech way, in a way that's
very friendly to everybody.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So I'm sure
you're all as excited
about this as we are and you're
probably wondering how
you can get started.
So yesterday, we put up
a Forms Quickstart.
It's an easy, five
minute tutorial.
If you've ever done any of the
Apps Script Quickstarts, it
should be pretty familiar.
And you can get there by going
to developers/googl
e.com/apps-script.
It should be right at
the top of the page
when you load it up.
Second, as Eric mentioned
earlier, you already have Apps
Script installed, so head to
script.google.com and get going.
Just try writing something.
And finally, write
something cool.
I'm sure some ideas
are bubbling.
You've come up with something
maybe just watching us.
And if you write something cool
and you come by the Apps
Sandbox and show us, we'd like
to see it, and if we like it,
you'll get a t-shirt.
ERIC KOLEDA: These are some
really cool looking t-shirts,
by the way.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
So thank you so much.
And we're going to do some
question and answer.
If you could try to come
up to the mics for the
Q&A, that'd be great.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I had two.
One, when you create a form
programatically, is every form
persisted or do you have a way
to define whether it's
temporary or just that once,
or does it live forever?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Every
form is persisted.
It'll show up in your Drive.
But you can use the Drive app
to delete forms that you no
longer need.
You can do it through
Drive itself.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it is
possible to kind of script the
finding of the forms you have as
well as the maintenance of
them-- moving them
into folders,
deleting them, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: And how would you say
one should determine where
the usage cutoff is here?
A little five person business
as opposed to trying to use
this on a massive scale?
Where would we want
to cut that off?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, defining these
mini-workflows, I kind of made
up the term myself.
Figuring out where the
right technology
is part of the challenge.
There is a point in which a
custom application makes
sense, but I think there is
a large middle ground.
I've seen some very complex
form-related workflows, tiers
and tiers of forms that all
interact with each other.
And certainly, you have to weigh
the pros and cons, but I
think that it's a pretty meaty
area to tackle with forms.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: You said you inserted
the script at the
Form level, but you can insert
it in any of the other ways
where we can create scripts.
So I could have it in a web
app, I could have it in a
spreadsheet, or is it
only limited there?
And if it's not limited there,
where do you trap the
onFormSubmit event
in that case?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So
regardless of where the script
lives, whether it's attached to
a form or not, you can use
the ScriptApps trigger builders
to listen to forms.
So you can have one script
listening to many forms
response events.
ERIC KOLEDA: So you could use--
and I think we have some
demos we've done in the past of
a spreadsheet bound script
creating forms, or a
web app deployed
script creating forms.
It's really not tied.
But when you are tied to a form,
it makes it a lot easier
to access that form.
We have a function,
getActiveForm, which just
automatically finds and
accesses the form it's
attached to.
Over on this side?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So one of the things that you
guys had on your dinner form
was putting in your information,
and that's
actually a common thing that
I see all the time as well.
OK, what's your name,
your email address.
Is there any direction, or
maybe there is already a
feature, to just sign in,
whether you have Google+ or
something, and just say, OK,
this form, you have to sign in
to use it and then take
it from there?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Right now,
if you are a Google Apps for
your domain user or Apps for
Education user, you can
enforce requiring sign in and
also collecting emails.
If you're on a regular Gmail
account, you can't do that
right now, but it is something
that we've heard from our
users and we're going
to be looking into.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I had a couple questions.
The email validation--
because I was creating a form
and then I realized it's an
email address.
Is that built into Google Forms
and can I use this to
force it to look like
an email address?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: That's
another big request from our
users, and with the new version
of Forms that launched
this past February, we're
looking to add a lot more
features coming up, and so
it's something we're
definitely looking at.
AUDIENCE: Can I do it with
Apps Script with the
integration?
Can I get to that level?
ERIC KOLEDA: One point to
clarify with how Apps Script
and Forms interact is that you
have access to a couple
different events you can tie
into when the Form Designer is
opened, when the Form Designer
and Edit takes place, and when
someone finishes the last page
of a form, when they hit the
final Submit.
But you cannot currently
use Apps Script in the
intermediary processes of
filling out a form-- so when
someone fills out a field
doing a validation
immediately, or when someone
goes from one page to another,
you don't have that
kind of a tie-in.
So it is possible to build a
script that, when a form a
submitted, you scan the data,
look for errors, and then send
them a notification, but you
cannot do that while they're
still in the form filling
out experience.
AUDIENCE: But there's
a plan to add?
Because there's a whole bunch
of validate cases that are
missing in Google Forms,
like email?
And another question
is, is there
integration with Google Wallet?
You talked about event
registration.
You could actually use this,
integrate it with Google
Wallet, have them fill out their
name and then pay, too.
Is that possible today?
ERIC KOLEDA: It's interesting.
Not today, I don't think.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Not today.
AUDIENCE: And another
question is mobile.
Let's say there's
20 questions.
On mobile, there's already
a mobile version, right?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
So we already have a mobile
version of the
Form Response page.
It uses mobile friendly
CSS and HTML.
And things like our new Date
Picker are using the HTML5
Date Picker, so it works
really well on iPhones,
Android devices, using the
Native OS level pickers.
AUDIENCE: That's really good.
Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes, over here?
AUDIENCE: So I'm interested in
building an offline mobile
client that talks to Forms.
I'm wondering if this allows
me to do that through some
sort of more reasonable API,
or is Forms going to get an
API at some point
in the future?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So we do
have an API in Apps Script for
constructing responses
and submitting them.
So it's a pretty good API.
It doesn't require you to do
what-- in the past, you'd have
to construct your own
Post Request and
send it to our server.
Now, you can construct a first
level, good, rich response and
submit it that way.
AUDIENCE: But does the API allow
me to pull down what the
form spec actually is?
So can I load that form in an
offline client, fill it out,
and then send it?
Because right now, presumably,
I can just send a response,
but if I don't know what that
form is, how do I do that?
ERIC KOLEDA: If you're using
Apps Script at least, you can
definitely read the structure
of the form, figure out what
all the fields are, figure out
what all the options are, and
then also very easily construct
a new response that
you can then submit
to that form.
So there's some capabilities
there.
I don't know if it'll fit your
exact use case, but it's worth
looking into.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ERIC KOLEDA: Over here?
AUDIENCE: Kind of an aside to
scripts itself, with form
submittal, is there going to
be any future plans to
restrict submittal to circles,
groups, and OUs?
Is that something
that we might be
looking at in the future?
Instead of just a global,
you're either inside the
organization or you're outside
the organization, I'm just
thinking specifically for
education, where you could
restrict to a student
OU or a staff OU for
those kind of things.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: That's
interesting.
Right now, we do only support
the organizational level
restriction, but it's
definitely something
interesting to look
at going forward.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: And once
again, using Apps Script, it's
not as ideal, but for instance,
if you required the
email address of your user,
you could then, after they
submit the form, determine
whether or not they are in a
certain group, determine if they
are in a certain circle.
So you have to do it after the
submission, but you could
then, perhaps, invalidate that
response or send them some
sort of feedback.
Just going to go to the
microphone over here.
AUDIENCE: So I know you're
focused on mini-workflows, but
sometimes forms can be pretty
lengthy and become medium
workflows and there's some value
in users being able to
save and come back.
Do you have any best practice
or suggestion or any way at
all to support a user to save
and come back, even if it
required them authenticating?
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: So I've
actually, in playing with the
API, written something that can
do this using the UI App
or HTML service to build my own
version of the form with a
little key that I made up
that allows the user to
come back with it.
But we don't have anything
that's first party as part of
Apps Script and Forms itself.
AUDIENCE: And you couldn't do
that with the regular Forms
because you don't get to run
your JavaScript while the form
is being filled out.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Correct.
AUDIENCE: So no good
way right now.
All right, thanks.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, no problem.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: So I'm going to speak
more from a start-up
standpoint.
You already mentioned about
the education part.
So assistants or professors
needs students to fill forms,
so let's say they don't have any
technical skills to create
those forms and you create a UI
where they can create their
own UI quizzes, et cetera.
So my question is going to be,
is the API that good to create
such elements on the fly,
meaning they will pick the
questions, fill the forms they
want, radio buttons or select
boxes, et cetera, that will be
able to will talk to the API
and create those elements
for them?
And then the emails that they
will receive the response to.
Can this be also set separately
from my account?
Let's say I have a Google
account but they don't, they
will provide their email
addresses and they want to
collect their responses
through that email.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I'd say it sounds like we're
flexible enough to
handle all of that.
I mean, the key takeaway, I
think, for what the FormApp
can do is currently everything
that you can do in the UI.
So if there's check boxes in
the Designer, there's check
boxes in Apps Script.
AUDIENCE: But can this be
created by the API?
That's my question.
They want to create something
and as a developer, I'm just
providing the service.
They will pick the elements,
place it on the UI.
Then I will take this UI,
programmatically, I'm going to
create on the fly through
the API, and--
ERIC KOLEDA: I think what we
showed today in our demo was
using a form as that custom UI,
but you could build your
own separate UI that's, let's
say, tailored to that specific
kind of problem you're solving
where they just enter a lot
less information and then you
take that information from
your custom UI and use
it to create a form.
So I think that definitely, all
the tools and the pieces
are there to allow
you to do that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You've been mentioning
the HTML service,
and I'm not familiar with that
at all before today, and
someone else just mentioned
JavaScript.
Can you use that HTML service
to inject any client side to
do validation of your own things
like that, right there
in the browser?
ERIC KOLEDA: I know we were
talking a little bit about
this problem.
It's definitely something a lot
of people want, is to do
that validation during
the fill out flow.
And so I think we're going
to think more about it.
But currently today, the only
time we can inject is after
the form's submitted.
So it is a little limiting.
You can't today use the HTML
service or use the JavaScript
capabilities within the
form filling out flow.
I think some of the right
technologies are there.
We've just got to see if
they all fit together.
AUDIENCE: I work for a school
and we have a lot of external
systems, and one of the biggest
questions I'm going to
have is, what kind of
third party system
can integrate with?
Does it need a certain API?
Does it need to be RESTful?
What are the limitations
there?
ERIC KOLEDA: So the different
connectors that we use and
that are popular, the biggest
one is URL Fetch App.
This allows you to make any sort
of Get Post request, you
can pass your own
custom headers.
You can therefore interact
with any HTTP-based
API, any REST API.
So it's the sky's
the limit there.
You have to actually do the HTTP
requests, so you have to
have some understanding of that,
but that opens it up to
a really large number of APIs.
We do have support for OAuth 1
currently, and we have some
sample code showing how you can
use OAuth 2 based APIs.
And then we also provide
connectors for SQL, so we have
a JDBC connector that
allows you to
connect to SQL databases.
And then we also have
a SOAP connector.
If you have a really old, legacy
SOAP service, you're
probably unhappy that you still
have that service, but
you can connect to it
via Apps Script.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
plan for maybe
an Oracle JDBC connector?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
So I think the JDBC we have
today, if I remember
correctly, is Oracle, MySQL, MS
SQL, so you should be good.
AUDIENCE: Not if you can send
somebody a document which
executes scripts.
Doesn't that open
a security risk?
ERIC KOLEDA: Security risk.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: No,
I don't think so.
ERIC KOLEDA: Especially within
an organization if you check
the check box that says, only
people within my organization
can fill it out, that definitely
limits the scope
down a lot.
But the other thing I guess is
being wary that if you have a
public form and you have a
script that's reacting to it,
that you understand
what you're doing.
I guess one of the key points
about the triggers that we
didn't go into too much detail
on is that when Matt creates a
trigger on his form,
the trigger always
runs as Matt's identity.
So you're never taking the
identity of the person filling
out the form.
You don't have access to that.
That is separate.
So anyone in the world could
fill out your form with or
without a Google account.
Their information is
separate and safe.
The trigger, when it runs,
it runs as Matt.
It has access to Matt's
Calendar, Matt's
Drive, Matt's Docs.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just one question, also
complements one of your answers.
One question is, do think that
you're going to have a field
sooner or later which allows you
to link to a Google Doc or
upload a file of some sort and
store it in a Drive folder or
something like that?
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
Upload.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Upload?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: That would
definitely be cool.
People have asked for it in the
past, so it's definitely
something we've considered.
But right now, we don't--
AUDIENCE: Not.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: It's
not launched right now.
AUDIENCE: And also, just to
comment on one of your answers
before about to figure out how
to scale this, at what point
is it OK for a small
organization or go huge scale?
The limitation there is on
the processing time.
You have limitations
on Apps Script.
I can't remember the
exact numbers.
I think it's 60 minutes or
something a day or something,
and after that, you need to
scale up to App Engine or
something like that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So Apps Script does have
some limitations.
I think what you're referring
to is they've got a five or
six minute processing time
on a script reaction.
So if you're doing more than
five or six minutes worth of
work, you either have to try to
batch it up in some sort of
away or maybe turn to
another solution.
And I think it's true with all
technologies, there's a time
when you eventually
grow out of it.
So I tried to show the
progression from email to
spreadsheet to something else.
I think people, the natural--
and I think probably correct
tendency-- is to do the simplest
thing that solves
your problem today, and then
when you grow out of it,
migrate to another solution.
I don't think there's any
solution I've ever seen, a
technology, where it works just
as well for the simplest
case as it does for
the best case.
There's always going to be the
need to revise it, revamp it,
and restructure it as the
problem space grows.
And so I think with Forms and
Apps Script, you are going to
find that maybe someday, if it
blows up and it's the most
popular form we've ever seen,
that you may need to change
some things that you're doing.
But I'd say when you think about
the problems that you
have, you'll start to see ones
that make sense with Forms and
Apps Script.
AUDIENCE: I've got a slightly
more general question about
Apps Script.
One of the benefits that's often
touted is that you don't
need an IDE to use it, but I'm
quite attached to my IDE.
Is there any way to upload or
download Apps Scripts outside
of just copy and paste
in the browser?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's a very popular request
we've gotten.
People have definitely
been asking for that.
We've gotten some of the bits
in place right now.
It's not fully baked, but
hopefully in the coming weeks
and months, we'll have
some more good news
about that for you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: I'm sorry, last
question in yellow because
we're out of time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
someone else's question, with
Apps Script in general, could
you fire off some sort of a
set of codes that, say,
creates a Google Drive folder
and emails somebody a link to
that to provide an upload
process kind of
indirectly that way?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
MATTHEW ZIEGELBAUM: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, definitely.
Actually, talking about upload,
it's not going to be
in the form, so there's not
going to be a little Browse
button just yet, but because we
have all of these different
connectors into sending emails,
into getting URLs,
into creating shared folders,
I think there is some
capabilities to solve it in
more of a roundabout way.
Well, thank you everybody
for coming today.
We had a great time.
Once again, please come by the
Chrome and Apps booth, say
hello to us, show
us your script,
get an awesome t-shirt.
Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]